[Music]
said i shall set forth against the
tangut people
he counted his troops anew and in the
autumn of the year of the dog set forth
riding his steed yosuto boro on the way
hunted the many wild asses of arbucha
when the wild asses passed close by them
joseto boro took fright
ching his heart fell off the horse and
his body being in great pain he halted
at chohaat
he spent that night there on the
following morning yesi khatun said
princes and commanders consult each
other on what to do the han has spent
the night his body hot with fever
the princes and commanders assembled and
tolui cherby of the hong kong advised as
follows
the tongue good people are ones who have
towns with pounded earth walls are ones
who live in permanent camps they won't
leave carrying off their towns with
pounded earth walls they won't leave
abandoning their permanent camps
let us withdraw then when the khan's
body has cooled down we shall set out
again
when he spoke thus all the princes and
commanders agreed with his words and
petitioned chingashan accordingly but
ching is han said the tongue good people
will say that we turned back because we
lost heart however if we send envoys to
them and watch right here at churchat
which turn my illness takes and withdraw
after considering their reply that would
be fine
and so he sent envoys to carry the
following message
in the past you said we the tongued
people shall be your right wing
you did not keep your promise and did
not give me troops but came out with
mocking words
of the tangot said
i did not speak the mocking words
thereupon ashagambu of the tangoth said
i spoke the mocking words as for now if
you mongols who are used to fighting say
let us fight
when his words were conveyed to
chingashan his body was still hot with
fever chingus han said
this is enough
when one lets oneself be addressed so
boastfully how can one withdraw
even if we die let us challenge their
boasts and saying eternal heaven you be
the judge he moved in the direction of
al-shai
this video has been kindly sponsored by
war and order the medieval fantasy
strategy game
just as the mongols tour across eurasia
in the early 13th century you too can
try building an empire yourself war and
order is set on crete and as a
descendant of the gods you can build
castles and alliances to wipe out your
enemies you can recruit troops and
cultivate beasts and they can go on
expeditions to increase combat power
even genghis khan didn't have a dragon
there is not only a wealth of
development lines in war and order but
it also has a multiplayer pvp mode
fighting with allies you can rule the
planet and dominate the entire server
you can use time attack gameplay with
allies to defeat the enemy and there are
many cross server battles in the game
there are also plenty of mini games so
you can see if you can beat your enemy's
score so click on the link in the
description to enjoy an exclusive sixty
dollars worth of gifts to start you off
on your conquests thanks again to warren
order for supporting history content on
youtube
when the people of the feldworld tents
had been brought to allegiance in the
year of the tiger they all gathered in
the source of the onan river they
hoisted the white standard with nine
tails and there they gave chingushan the
title of han having thus completed the
task of setting the mongol people in
order ching gizhan said to those who
sided with me when i was establishing
our nation i shall express my
appreciation and having formed units of
a thousand i shall appoint them
commanders of a thousand
chingishan made commanders of a thousand
those who had established the state with
him and who had suffered with him
forming units of a thousand he appointed
the commanders of a thousand and of a
hundred and ten forming units of ten
thousand he appointed the commanders of
ten thousand the commanders of ten
thousand and of a thousand to whom
rewards seemed appropriate he rewarded
those who were to be commended he
commended
in the year of the sheep ching is han
set out against the hittat people he
took vajeu crossed over hunagan daban
took sundivo and sent jaev and gui gunak
bata as vanguards on reaching chubchill
seeing that the chubchill pass was
defended jev there and then said we
should entice them and get them to move
and come after us
then let us put them to the test so
saying he turned back when they
discovered that he had turned back the
hittat troops said let us pursue him and
they went in pursuit until the valleys
and the mountains were completely
covered with them upon reaching the spur
of san divo jiv turned back rushed forth
against the enemies who were approaching
in successive waves and routed them
ching ishan pressing on with the main
body of the army dislodged the hitard
from their positions crushed the valiant
and bold julian troops of the harahit
and the jerchet slaying them until they
were like heaps of rotten logs as far as
chubcheel
zev took the gate of chubchill and after
he had captured the passes and crossed
over them chingashan pitched camp at
shear addicter launching the attack on
jongdur he sent troops to various towns
and cities ordering them to attack when
jongdur was under siege a high official
of the altan han on jing ching sang
advised the altanhan as follows
this is the destiny and favorable time
decreed by heaven and earth
could it be the time has come when the
great throne will pass to a new ruler
the mongols are coming in great might
they have crushed our valiant and bold
elite julian troops of the harahit and
the churchit slaying them until they
were utterly destroyed even chabtchill
pass on which we were lying they have
rested from us if we now set our troops
in order and send them out to fight
should they again be crushed by the
mongols they will no doubt scatter and
return to their various cities and if we
rally them against their will they will
turn against us and will no longer be
our friends
if you the altan han grant permission
let us for the present submit and come
to terms with the ruler of the mongols
when they came and submitted themselves
chingashan agreed to their proposal he
ordered back the troops that were
attacking the various towns and withdrew
in the course of that military campaign
chingishan set out towards the tungut
people when moving in their direction he
reached their country
of the tangoth people said i shall
submit and becoming your right wing i
shall serve you
and he offered his daughter called
chakha to chingashan
further brahman khan said hearing of
chingashan's fame we were in awe of you
now your august person has arrived you
have come to us and we are indeed owed
by your majesty
being lord we the tongued people have
said we shall become your right wing and
we shall serve you when we serve you
know that
we are the ones who live in permanent
camps
we are the ones who have towns with
pounded earth walls
and so when we become your companions in
waging a swift campaign in fighting a
deadly combat we shall not be able to
hasten into a swift campaign we shall
not be able to fight
a deadly combat
having thus obtained the submission of
the altan han of the hittat people named
ahutai and ilahu burhan of the tangued
people in that campaign in the year of
the sheep chingus hahn returned home and
set up camp on the sari step
[Music]
in the year of the hair chingish han set
out against the sartul people crossing
the alai
from among the ladies he took with him
khulan khaton and having entrusted
ochign nuyan from among his younger
brothers with the main base camp he
moved forth
he sent xiv as vanguard he sent subatai
in support of jev and sent tohucha in
support of subatai he sent envoys to
burhan of the tangut people with a
message saying you said that you would
be my right wing as the sartul people
have broken my golden halter i have set
out to call them to account for their
action
you set forth too as the right wing of
my army
when the message he had sent was
received and before burhan could utter a
word ashagambu forestalling him said
since chingashan's forces are incapable
of subjugating others why did he go as
far as becoming han
so saying he did not dispatch auxiliary
troops to him and sent back the envoys
with haughty words
thereupon chingus han said how can we
bear being spoken to in this manner by
asha gambu the best plan would be for us
to send troops against them at once by
detouring in their direction what
difficulty would there be in that but
now when we are indeed in the direction
of other people
let that pass
if i am protected by eternal heaven when
i come back pulling in strongly my
golden reigns then surely this matter
shall be dealt with
jalaldin sultan and han melik moved
against chinggis han
shige hutohu went as vanguard before
ching's han jaladin sultan and han melek
fought with shige hutuhu they defeated
shige hutuhu and pressing on approached
as far as chinggis han
at that moment however jev subatai and
tohuchar came in from behind geraldine
sultan and khan malik overcame them and
utterly destroyed them
by so doing they prevented them from
joining forces in the cities of buhari
semesgab and udorah they pursued them as
far as the shin river and when being
pressed the sardul started throwing
themselves into it many of them did
indeed perish there in the shin river
jalaluddin sultan and khan malik fled
upstream along it saving their lives
ching is han advanced along the shin
river upstream and set up camp in the
baruan
then ching is han returning from the
barawan plain sent his three sons jochi
cheddai and ogade saying cross the amui
river with the troops of the right wing
and set up camp at the city of urangichi
he sent tolui saying set up combat eru
isabor and many other towns ching is han
himself encamped the city of urar the
three sons jochi chadai and
sent the following request our troops
are completely assembled we have reached
the city of orengetchi of the three of
us according to whose words should we
act
upon their request chingishan sent a
message to them ordering that they
should act according to the words of
oggaday
then chingishan having brought the city
of urdura to submission set out from the
city of udarar and pitched camp at the
city of semesgab
setting out from the city of samasgarb
he pitched camp at the city of buhar
thereupon chengizhan waited for bala and
spent the summer at the ridge of the
altan jorgen in the former summer
quarters of the sultan
[Music]
from there he sent messengers to tolery
saying the weather has become warm the
other troops must set up camp too you
come and join us
when he sent this message toleray had
captured the cities of iru isabor and
others had destroyed the city of sistan
and was just destroying the city of
chucharen when the messengers gave him
this message doloy having destroyed the
city of chocharen returned to pitch camp
and joined chingashan
jochi chadai and ogadi these three sons
of chingashan subjugated the city of
urangechi they shared the people of the
cities among all three of them but did
not give chingishan a share just as
chingashan was addressing them with
reprimands and admonitions hong hai
hochi hong khatar hochi and chomahan
horchi these three quiver bearers also
petitioned chingus han as follows
like grey falcons that have just begun
training the suns are barely learning
how to wage a military campaign and at
such a time you rebuke them in this way
piling abuse on them
why
for fear lest the sun's being afraid
will lose heart
from the place where the sun sets to the
place where it rises there are enemy
people if you incite us your tibetan
dogs and send us on a mission with our
strength increased by heaven and earth
we shall bring back for you enemy people
gold silver satin goods and subjects
if you say which people we say here in
the west there is one called the
halabhai sultan of the bakhtart people
let us move against him and so they
petitioned him the han was appeased by
these words and his anger abated
chingashan approved their proposal he
sent trommahan on a campaign against the
bhaktat people and the halabhai's sultan
ching gizhan spent seven years in the
country of the sartul people and then
chingashan returned home
on the way he spent the summer on the
river erdesh in the autumn of the year
of the hen the seventh year of the
campaign he settled at his palaces in
the black forest
after spending the winter there
chingashan said i shall set forth
against the tangot people he counted his
troops anew and in the autumn of the
year of the dog set forth burhan of the
tangord said i did not speak the mocking
words thereupon ashagambu said i spoke
the mocking words as for now if you
mongols who are used to fighting say
let us fight
i have an encampment in the alishai i
have tents of thin woolen cloth i have
camels laden with goods
let us fight there
he sent this message to chingus han
chingish han moved in the direction of
alishai he arrived there and fought with
ashagambu he overcame ashagambu and
forced him to barricade himself up on
the alashai he captured ashegambo and
plundered his people who had tents of
thin woolen cloth who had camels laden
with goods until they were blown to the
winds like hearth ashes
he then gave the following order kill
the valiant the bold the manly and the
fine tangots and let the soldiers take
for themselves as many of the common
tangots as they can lay hands on and
capture
chingashan spent the summer on chasito
mountain
he sent troops against the tangots who
had tents of thin woolen cloth who had
camels laden with goods and who with
ashegambo had made for the mountains and
were offering resistance he caused his
troops to plunder them as planned until
they were utterly destroyed then showing
favour to borchu and muhali he ordered
that they should take as much booty as
in their judgment their strength could
carry
chingashan moved away from the chassidu
mountain and set up camp at the city of
uragai after setting out from the city
of urahi while he was destroying the
city of dermagay burhan came to pay
homage to chingashan on that occasion
when burhan paid homage chingishan felt
revulsion within his heart
on the third day chingashan issued an
order giving uluhu burhan the name
shidohu ching is han then ordered that
ilhoo be put to death and that talui
cherby seize and execute him with his
own hands
after he had plundered the tangot people
and making burhan change his name to
siddurhu had done away with him and
after having exterminated the tangled
people's mothers and fathers down to the
offspring of their offspring maiming and
taming chinggishan gave the following
order
[Music]
while i take my meals you must talk
about the killing and destruction of the
tangoth and say
maimed and tamed
they are no more
[Music]
because the tongue people gave their
word but did not keep it chingashan for
the second time took the field against
them having destroyed the tangoed people
chingashan came back and in the year of
the pig ascended to heaven
in the year of the rat the princes of
the right hand headed by chaday and batu
the princes of the left hand headed by
ochigen noyan yagu and yusunge the
princes of the center headed by talui
the princesses the imperial sons-in-law
the commanders of ten thousand and those
of a thousand all assembled in full
force
on the hilurin river in accordance with
the very decree by which chingishan had
nominated him
they installed ogiday han as han
ogedekhan having concluded the
installation of himself as han and the
transfer of the ten thousand guards on
internal duty together with the domain
of the center to himself held first of
all a consultation with his elder
brother chadai whereupon he sent okator
and mongetu on a campaign in support of
churmahan horchi who had taken the field
against the halabhai sultan of the
bhaktat people a people not dealt with
by his father chingus hahn
earlier on subatai campaigning against
mechet menchroman heibe and other cities
had crossed the river's ideal and jayach
rich in waters and it reached as far as
the hanglin kipchat bajigit orosut asut
sesut
and herald peoples as subutai had been
put in a difficult position by these
peoples ogedekhan sent forth batu bhuri
guruk monge and several other princes in
support of subatai having put all the
harahuchi in charge of the great palaces
in the year of the hair ogde khan set
out against the hittat people he sent
fourth sheer vers vanguard he thus
crushed the hitta troops slaying them
until they were like heaps of rotten
logs
he crossed chabtchel and ordered his
troops to advance and attack their towns
and cities in every direction there ogde
han fell ill
when he lost his speech and was in great
distress various shamans and soothsayers
were ordered to divine the cause of the
illness when they divide by inspecting
the entrails of victims and said to the
lords and rulers of the lands and rivers
we shall give a substitute for the harn
people gold and silver cattle and food
the illness did not abate when they
divined further by inspecting the
entrails and said could a person from
the hans family serve as a substitute
the han opening his eyes requested water
drank it and asked what has happened the
shamans then reported to the han as
follows when we say could a person from
the hans family serve as substitute the
illness abates
now your order shall decide
after they had made their report the han
said who was at my side from among the
princes to these words prince talui who
was at his side said in truth if my
elder brother the han dies the numerous
mongol peoples would be left orphans the
hit out people would rejoice at their
good fortune
i shall take the place of my elder
brother the han
thus he spoke and as the shamans made
their incantations prince de louis drank
the magic water
then he sat for a moment and said
i have become drunk
while i recover from my drunkenness let
elder brother the han decide how best to
take care of his younger brothers who
are orphaned and young
and of his younger sister-in-law who is
widowed until they are able to look
after themselves
i have said all i have to say
such is the manner in which he died
[Music]
then ogerhan destroyed the altan han and
gave him the name seyuse he despoiled
him of his gold silver gold embroidered
and patterned saturns possessions
piebald horses and young slaves having
established scouts and garrison troops
and having appointed resident
commissioners in namjin zhengdu and in
cities everywhere he peacefully returned
home setting up camp at harahurum
you